- HEY, DUDE,
THEY GIVE YOU PUDDING, MAN.
- HEY, DUDE.
- YOU GO IN THE CAFETERIA,
AND YOU JUST SWIPE A CARD,
AND THEY GIVE YOU
AS MUCH PUDDING AS YOU WANT.
- OH, COOL.
- WHAT'S THIS, YOUR SCHEDULE?
- YEAH, YEAH.
- WHAT'S UP WITH ALL
THIS THEATER, MAN?
- WELL, I'M A THEATER MAJOR,
SO--
YEAH, I CAUGHT THE ACTING BUG
PRETTY BAD.
BUT YEAH, I ALREADY AUDITIONED
FOR THE FALL PRODUCTION--
LES MISERABLES.
- THAT'S COOL.
SO CAN YOU, LIKE,
CRY ON COMMAND AND STUFF?
- OH, YEAH, IT'S EASY.
THINK OF SOMETHING REALLY SAD
REAL QUICK.
LIKE, A BUNDLE OF BABIES
EXPLODING,
OR, LIKE, DOGS EXPLODING.
OR, LIKE--LIKE, MAYBE
YOUR MOM'S REALLY SICK,
OR YOU, LIKE, WALKED IN
ON, LIKE--ON HER RAPE
YOU NOW, STOP HIM--
YOU CAN'T STOP HIM
BECAUSE HE'S BIGGER THAN YOU.
LIKE, YOU JUST THINK OF THAT...
- OH, THAT HIT SO CLOSE
TO HOME FOR ME.
MY DOG ACTUALLY EXPLODED
WHEN I WAS A KID.
- I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T MEAN TO--
- IT'S OKAY.
YOU ARE A REALLY GOOD ACTOR.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE LIKE
SEANN WILLIAMS SCOTT.
YOU'RE AT
A SEANN WILLIAMS SCOTT LEVEL.
- THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
IT'S JUST LIVING TRUTHFULLY
IN IMAGINARY CIRCUMSTANCES,
AND WHATEVER.
ENOUGH ABOUT ME.
WHAT'S--WHAT'S ON YOUR SCHEDULE?
- OH, ME...
WOMEN'S SEXUALITY,
SEXUAL REVOLUTION,
THE HUMAN BODY,
REMEDIAL MATH...
THE BIBLE AS LITERATURE.
I'M DOING THAT FOR MY GF.
- GET THE HECK OUT OF HERE.
YOU ALREADY SCORED A GIRLFRIEND?
- OH, NO,
SHE'S BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL.
WE'RE, LIKE, CRAZY RELIGIOUS,
THOUGH.
WE ALWAYS GET ON OUR KNEES...
AND PRAY TO JESUS.
NOT ORALLY, PLEASE.
- OH.
- YOU KNOW, SHE'S ACTUALLY
COMING NEXT WEEKEND.
WE'LL GO SEE YOU ACT THE [bleep]
OUT OF THAT PLAY, DUDE.
- UH, THAT'S NOT FOR A WHILE.
PLUS, I ALREADY GOT CAST
AS, LIKE, A POLICE OFFICER.
I'M JUST IN THE BACKGROUND.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE LINES.
- WHAT?
- YEAH, I KNOW.
IT'S JUST A POPULARITY CONTEST
WHEN YOU GET DOWN TO IT.
- WHOA, MAN.
I'M, LIKE, THE MOST
POPULAR DUDE IN MY HIGH SCHOOL
NOW THAT I'VE GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I AM THROWING YOU...
A PARTY, BRO,
SO YOU CAN INFILTRATE
THAT THEATER-NERD CREW.
- LIKE IN MEAN GIRLS.
- YES!
- [laughs]
- YOU KNOW, MEAN GIRLS IS
MY FAVORITE MOVIE.
- IT'S MINE TOO.
both: THE DVD SPECIAL
COMMENTARY...
- OH!
- OH, MY GOD. OH, MY--
- LISTEN TO IT.
LINDSAY JUST TELLS ALL.
- OH, YEAH.
- TINA FEY.